i think in one of the videos i watched
you mentioned
uh don knuth uh well
at least recommending his uh you know
his
his book is something people should read
oh yeah but
in terms of you know theoretical
computer science
do you do you see something beautiful in
in
that has been inspiring to you speaking
of n log n
in your work on programming languages
that's in the in the that whole world of
algorithms and complexity
and you know these kinds of more formal
mathematical things
um or did that not really stick with you
in your programming life
it did stick pretty clearly for me
because
one of the things that i care about is
being able to
sort of look at a piece of code and and
be able to prove to myself that it works
um you know and
you know so so for example i find that
um
i'm i'm at odds with many of the people
around me
over um issues about like
how you lay out
a piece of software right you know so
so software engineers get really cranky
about how they format their the
documents that are the programs you know
where they put new lines and where they
put you know the braces
the braces and all the rest of that
right
and i tend to go
for a style that's very dense uh to
minimize the white space
um yeah well to maximize
the amount that i can see at once
right so i like to be able to see a
whole function
and to understand what it does rather
than have to go scroll scroll scroll and
remember right yeah i'm with you on that
yeah that's
and people don't like that
yeah i've had i i've had you know
multiple
times when engineering teams have
uh staged what was effectively an
intervention
[Laughter]
um you know where they they invite me to
a meeting and everybody's arrived before
me and they sort of all look at me and
say
james about your coding style
[Laughter]
i'm sort of an odd person to be
programming because i don't think
very well verbally
i am just naturally a slow reader
i'm what most people would call a visual
thinker
so when you think about a program what
do you what do you see
i see pictures right so
when i look at a piece of code on a
piece of paper
it very quickly gets transformed into a
picture
um and you know it's almost like a
piece of machinery with you know this
connected to that and
like these gears yeah
yeah i i see them more more like that
than i see the
the the the sort of verbal structure or
the lexical structure of
of letters so then when you look at the
program that's why you want to see it
all in the same place
then you could just map it to something
visual yeah and just kind of like
like it leaps off the page at me and
yeah
what are the inputs where the outputs
what the heck is this thing doing
yeah and yeah getting a whole vision of
it
you